you prepare for the worst and be
pleasantly surprised by the best but if
you haven't prepared for it by the time
it hits that's a bone meal I'm just
another animal out here on the Arctic I
am a food group I'm not top of the food
chain so every day every morning every
night I've got to look for predators
it's always a challenge of staying alive
day-to-day back there in the room I just
got in asleep heard one be heavy you can
tell it the footprints its I'm an I'm
ten to one pretty sure it's either the
wolf or the Wolverine tomorrow morning
when it's light
I'll go look at tracks tonight a son of
a [ __ ] got to get in here to get me if
anybody wants to play poker I got the
winning hand right here it's a Wolverine
over there I need to think like my
opponent does and I'll smart him so I'm
gonna get right up in his grill and let
him know two can play this game by me
going into their territory boom boom
boom boom it's a posturing and warning
you know I had to push play my dominance
over his dominance and he's left the
area I like the feeling that I am strong
and I can take care of it that's the
biggest thing
being out here has done what can I do
for myself if I can't do it this way the
way everybody else does it well how can
I do it in a way that works for
you learn you can be quite capable of
taking care of yourself I need to bring
those
unleaded fuel from the outside to the
inside
Oh
I'm on a physical labor it takes to be
here do this on my own
Wow mom [ __ ] there's nobody to help you
you've got to pick it up and then you've
got them and to repent on everybody else
to get me there is currently
unacceptable
I don't know that's three four hundred
pounds of fun there
unleaded highly explosive that's not a
good feeling every day is full of
surprises that's one of them you know so
I'll be surprised if I get your ass off
your you know couch and deal with it if
a bear decides that I look like a Scooby
Snack I need to protect myself as long
as it is within the season I will
actively pursue that there I think I see
something we need to get closer get
ready in case the charges
shakin that is a big thing for me to
actively pursue a bear proud of myself
for doing it and overcoming some fears
especially as it was getting closer but
I also protected camp Thank You bear the
spirit will not go to waste and I accept
it a long time ago there's something
like this I might be the one laying
there not him this is one skirmish in
the battle on the other